- This piece, I mean, wow.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that piece is a--
- Look at that red.
I think it was
made in '25 or '26.
- You're right.
- They called it a Red Bug.
This was made by a company--
well, initially, Smith.
So it was called
the Smith Flyer.
And it had a fifth
wheel on the back.
There was a wheel on the
back, OK, that drove it.
And then later on,
in the teens, they
sold that to Briggs & Stratton.
And then a company
called Automotive
Electric Services bought this.
And they started putting
these electric motors on.
So the evolution of the Red
Bug or the Smith Flyer, this
is the last of it, with this
electric motor in this drive.
But yeah, they're super cool.
There's a picture up
in the house somewhere.
Walter's driving and
Beth's sitting beside him.
It's a very cool picture.
And they're, you know,
10 or 12 years old.
It was originally bought
by my uncle for his family.
Here's this a little
electric gadget that he
could just tool around in.
We drove it around
the sidewalks.
And he didn't really
like me to drive it.
So the Red Bug, OK,
I'm interested in that.
All right.
And I'm interested
in the sign.
OK.
Do you have a number
on the Packard sign?
Five to six.
In 1899, the Packard
automobile company
opened their doors.
And they were in business
until the late 1950s.
But in 1953, Packard
bought Studebaker
and became the
Studebaker-Packard Corporation.
I think five to six is doable,
just because of the chip
I can see in the top,
and it's been repainted.
If that chip wasn't there--
I haven't seen the
other side yet--
it'd be worth as much as 8,000.
When you get up on it, you
can see that there's been
some restoration to the sign.
There's some big chips
out of the porcelain.
The paintwork was done well
enough to where, from far away,
it looks amazing.
But the sign,
guys, the guys that
want the mint signs
that will pick it apart
will notice that right away.
They want mint stuff, almost
like a comic book collector,
when you're looking
at the yellowing
of the pages, and the edge, and
the cover, and all that stuff.
They look at signs that way.
What's also awesome is
the sign ring is there.
They're always missing.
What's it look like?
What's the back side?
[groans] Let me see here.
I think-- it's very
similar to the other side.
There's some-- there's
some big chips.
See where-- see where
this was repaired?
I mean, not repaired,
but repainted.
All right.
That's the same thing that's
going on the other side,
but it's not repainted.
Oo, aren't you so glad
you can see those now?
[laughs] Yeah, I
actually kind of am.
Yes.
- How about 45 on the sign?
- How about 55?
- Yeah, I can't.
I'm getting into-- I'm getting--
'cause I'm getting
into what it's worth.
That's my retail number.
That's not what
I can pay for it.
Why don't we do this?
I do 45 on the sign
and 5 on the car.
Hmm.
Could you throw another $500 in?
That makes it an even $10,000.
Yeah, I-- how about $5,000,
$4,500, and the grill?
And you're saying an
extra $500, right?
- Yes.
- Why don't we do an extra $200?
All right, we'll do it.
I like it.
I can see why the
family hired you.
- That's what I do.
- I like it. yeah.
I like it.
I love--
All right, very cool.